[Applaudissements]
heureusement que le tour a été inventé
en 1903 autrement on dirait qu'il a été
inventé pour la télé
cette image restera dans l'histoire du
tour de france beaucoup de renversements
dans cette étape scénariste qui aura
écrit un sport il aurait écrit il au
cyclisme pour l'affairé elf ou quatrième
car nous savons bien que plus d'audience
trombone plus le droit de télévision
seront seront importantes quand on
pourra bien renégocier
[Applaudissements]
notre objectif est oui vous avez raison
de faire de l'audience de donner
satisfaction aux téléspectateurs en
satisfactions sportives d'organisateurs
et satisfaction qu'on est intéressé
d'entrepreneurs
[Applaudissements]
il
croit on
excusez me richard je veux cougars voici
les derniers 200 mètres 180 m 160 m 150
mètres petit sous les acclamations de
deux vérins sous le règne de merckx
la télévision est vraiment entré dans le
coeur du peloton
bravo mr et si je le dis comme ça sur
l'antenne avec mont athos 4000 x 2000
voix je vais faire quelque chose de
fantastique et je suis content d'avoir
pu crier sur l'ante est un seigneur
cathodique le 15 juillet 1969
eddy merckx a conquis son premier
exploit sur le tour de france
une incroyable chevauchée solitaire de
130 km à travers l'ukraine
un champion de légende est née de la
trempe des copines bobet anquetil et
pour la première fois cette légende
s'écrit devant les caméras de la
télévision en direct avec merce le
cyclisme est entré dans l'ère moderne
parce que les grands exploits de merckx
ont coïncidé avec l'offensive de la
télévision c'est la raison d'être de
cette tribune
elle n'est pas enregistrée elle n'est
pas magnétoscope et elle n'est pas filmé
elle est en direct à la plus grande
gloire du tour de france et d'un tour de
france exceptionnel le direct un
challenge un défi pour les hommes de
télévision défi d'autant plus difficile
à relever pour le cyclisme que l'air de
jeu ce sont les routes de france et non
l'enceinte d'un stade pour en arriver à
la qualité actuelle des images du tour
de france le chemin a été long très long
ce fut un véritable combat mené par les
techniciens de la rtf puis de la sfp
contre l'essence même du tour de france
sa furtivité sam non visibilité
mazel messieurs on
bonjour
je ne décroche à michel vous voyez
pourquoi certaines ans maintenant non
ils ennuient pour l'instant daniel
malheureusement équitable sur andreu
merde merde je ne bouge pas et humain a
tenté de revenir en enroulant ce
développement mercadier de prendre la
manette est très importante parce qu'on
n'a probablement michel louis souvet
n'ya qui était notre leader donc an soit
170 n'avait de cesse que de nous
remonter contre merckx entre nous
pardonnez moi mais il appelait le grand
comme bell il s'auto il s'inventait un
ennemi au fond pour essayer de l'attaqué
hébron ça faisait passer lorsqu'on
lorsqu'on se rencontrer quoi les duels
entre grands champions tels coppi
bartali anquetil poulidor ont fait les
mines de la légende du tour dans la
presse écrite par contre pour les
techniciens de la télévision lé duel à
distance entre champions sont à l'époque
un cauchemar les moyens techniques alors
limitées ne permettent pas de montrer
simultanément l'exploit de cagnes a
hélas défaillances demeurent hx8 menus
dernière ocalia les commentateurs télé
en sont parfois réduits à faire de la
radio
[Applaudissements]
pour être
kagame
ballons jaunes avec de nombreuses
minutes et une avance considérable
cet exploit de ocaña me rappelle il a
raison les exploits d'antan de cobh
lettre de copies et domerc jean-michel
oui avec un autre cauchemar pour la
télévision
le mauvais temps les hélicoptères sont
cloués au sol la retransmission en
direct de la course est alors impossible
il faudra attendre encore 20 ans avant
que la télévision s'affranchissent des
aléas de la météo
ça a vraiment été un truc dame organise
les gars qui partait dans les champs
partout à droite à gauche puis s'arrêter
parce que mon frère y avait de l'eau
comme ça sur la route
un orage comme ça peut se passer et saas
et le cloud
dans la descente du col de mente aucune
image en direct
la télévision passe à côté dans les plus
grand drame de l'histoire du tour de
france ocaña qui avait laminé merckx
quatre jours auparavant chute et
abandonne en direct à la radio dans
l'échiquier j'ai effectué jusqu'à
présent je n'ai jamais eu la peur de
mourir c'était
envoyez tous les spectacles du courage
de la souffrance défaillance sur visage
marqué par la douleur sommes allant à
l'extrême limite de leurs possibilités
la légende des géants de la route des
forçats de la route
la télévision très vite va se
l'approprier autant d'image qui
donneront vie à cette légende doute
nourri depuis 1903 des métaphores
enflammé de la presse écrite
[Applaudissements]
oui à dire c'est des difficultés pour
respirer en défense ça ne se gagne pas
avec des seconds
on doit mourir attaquer attaquer
attaquer attaquer
[Musique]
la légende du cannibale eddy merckx est
aînés en direct en noir et blanc
cette fois c'est en couleurs qu'il sera
terrassé merckx caracole en tête suivi
de l'italien felice gimondi le champion
français bernard thévenet est lancée à
leur poursuite
les difficultés de la retransmission
télévisée occulte le moment crucial de
cette étape et rendent le récit de la
course
incompréhensible pouvoir quitter
maintenant ce groupe là pour retourner
vers la tête et savoir ce qui se passe
exactement alors que bernard thévenet
après un deuxième démarrage en faisant
exactement comme si nous étions sur
notre bicyclette pour revenir sur
l'avant de la course et à l'avant de la
course et bien
le 1er mai passé fait les séries m'ont
dit que je pourrais effectivement alors
attention et 90 s'était dit merci qui
dit qu'en fait en fait les frais du
monde ou alors je compte maintenant
quand même on a vu jim ont dit on va
encore retourner derrière avec la caméra
et bien bernard thévenet wii qui revient
va peut-être réussir à grignoter
quelques secondes supplémentaires à eddy
merckx au bout de la route
une petite tache jaune et aisément dire
voilà il a pu comprendre angers au point
et mais qu'il tend la belle à la
poursuite de qui alors là exactement ce
que possible quand même on a perdu l'air
alors merde alors et vous vous y
retrouvez
et oui oui tout le monde se pose la
question j'ai vraiment fait le lait les
400 derniers mètres mais amor amor amor
pense yeux de l'élu et de grignoter
quelques secondes je pensais jamais lu m
j'ai pris un peu moins de deux minutes
c'était dans le contexte à l'époque
c'était impensable d'imaginer qu'on
puisse reprendre deux minutes à mais
ressent en aussi peu de temps
malgré ce raté de télévision à praloup
c'est grâce à la télévision que bernard
thévenet acquiert instantanément une
immense popularité
il a terrassé le cannibale eddy merckx
l'invincible le lendemain une foule
énorme porte en triomphe son nouveau
héros sur les pentes du mythique col de
l'izoard
c'est incroyable public populaire
deviendra au fil des années l'un des
acteurs clés de la légende télévisée du
tour de france si j'étais cependant dans
dans un monde irréel un peu j'ai
l'impression que 25 ou 27 ans près jean
corne écrits de ces gens dans l'est dans
les oreilles j'avais l'impression d'être
leur porte drapeau lors leur étendard je
parle du thg tu es devenu a même pas
quelqu'un à la limite c'est quelque
chose de 2,2 représentatif pour eux je
sais que je faisais c'était pour eux ils
m'ont vraiment aidé parce que ça m'avait
vraiment sublime et
[Applaudissements]
il s'est échappé parcourir s'est échappé
on parle d'un condamné à mort s'est
échappé d'un prisonnier c'est déjà un
coureur s'est échappé et a coureurs
échappés tout d'un coup il est vêtu
d'une sorte de doha inde comme dans
l'est dans les livres qu'on avait deux
du catéchisme avec les les seins avec
des auréoles l'échappée il a son horreur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour moi le vélo c'est de la liberté
même si on fait ça avec une chaîne
[Musique]
félix lévitan et jacques goddet nous
pouvait rêver en 1975 meyer vainqueur à
bernard thévenet pour la première fois
avec la plus du président de la
république le tour de france terminé en
apothéose sur les champs-elysées devant
une foule de 500 1000 parisien
enthousiaste cela avait valeur de
symbole cette consécration sur l'avenue
la plus prestigieuse celle des
cérémonies du 14 juillet faisait entrer
le tour de france dans le patrimoine
national
les images sont reprises en direct par
la quasi totalité des chaînes de
télévisions membres de leur vie
renouveler l'intérêt médiatique de la
course générer des recettes
supplémentaires autant de raisons qui
poussent les organisateurs à multiplier
dans le courant des années 70 les demi
étape les pierres d'étape de départ deux
arrivées dans la même journée voire
trois et cela au détriment du temps de
sommeil et de récupération des coureurs
en 1978 le peloton manifeste son
ras-le-bol et durant quelques minutes
ils ne voudront pas d'un centimètre et
tous les courants étaient fatigués on
lundi à la grève depuis sept et mitry et
ensuite eh bien c'est bernard hinault
qui va franchir à pied la ligne sacrés
d'un peu de problèmes avec la mairie qui
nous avait reçus de valence d'agen le
j'ai revu le maire depuis jeudi sont
avait passé la lève on connaîtrait pas
talila nous savons que ça ça comme ça
vous voyez bernard hinault ici un regard
presque de défi à l'égard des
organisateurs jamais créé laitière
d'étape pour pouvoir apporter
précisément une certaine animation et
que tout ça c'est avant tout une
histoire de gros sous avant est une
histoire de sport créé votre répond
alors cela est proprement ridicule
d'abord ensuite je dirais qu néanmoins
nous n'avons pas à rougir de chercher à
faire des recettes qui nous permettent
d'organiser le tour de france dont il ne
faut tout de même pas oublier qu'il
coûte plus d'un milliard de centimes et
pour les organisateurs du tour de france
vous le savez aussi vous ne savez pas je
vous l'apprends il n'y a pas de
subvention gouvernementale
jacques goddet et félix lévitan
leurs rivalités leurs conflits pouvoir
leur animosité réciproque ne les auront
pas empêché de cohabiter à la tête du
tour pendant près de 40 ans face à la
télévision ces deux hommes de presse
écrite ont eu la même intuition
prémonitoire dès les premiers
balbutiements des direct télévisés ils
en ont mesuré les enjeux pour le
développement et la prospérité future du
tour de france à tel point que dès les
années 60 ils sont eux-mêmes devenus des
hommes de télévision nous allons oui
titre et paris en fait pour bernard
hinault bon schéma d'amis nos mamans
hinault ici qui embrasse son fils toutes
les familles se retrouvaient à paris
pour accueillir le petit bernard qui
remporte son premier tour de france
le gros animal ne sortant de son terrier
qu'à bon escient des surnoms du breton a
une capacité pulmonaire hors du commun
une volonté de faire telle est bernard
yves le blaireau parce que un moment de
temps dans le kloto tous les gens
s'interpeller en disant festif et béraud
et puis c'est resté sur moi et quand on
connaît l'animal
les règles sont jugées parfois c'est un
peu ça m'emmerde mai mais dans mon trou
j'attends donc et je pense je ressors
jeu sort les griffes et j'attaque
bernard hinault il son sale caractère
bernard hinault et son panache bernard
hinault et ses coups de gueule bernard
hinault
l'acteur idéal de ce feuilleton télévisé
à vocation mondiale qui est devenu le
tour de france lors des années 80 les
années hinault le sport spectacle prend
définitivement possession des écrans de
télévision il devient peu à peu une
vitrine commerciale télévisé d'une
efficacité redoutable et parfois un lieu
d'expression sociale
[Applaudissements]
nous
gagnant elysées c'est quelque chose de
fantastique
quand vous arrivez là y'a pas à dire ça
pince au coeur ça on est un héros en soi
même a même quelle que soit la place
comme je vous ai dit on finit le tour de
france c'est un monument au tour de
france ont fait part au tour de france
dans la dentelle
c'est ya des hauts des bas on s'offre on
rigole puis quand on arrive à paribas
c'est l'apothéose donc pour la première
fois hier une étape du tour de france a
été annulé et on arrive à denain usinor
la décision de fermer le train avant de
l'usiné en 1984 a été prise la veille
par le conseil d'administration
est ce que l'on pensait éviter arrive la
route est bloquée cette fermeture
d'usinor entraînera la reconversion
forcée ou le chômage pour 13 cents
ouvriers de france
ils demandent dans les agences
nationales wipf
quel est le taux de demandeurs d'emploi
ils verront que denain avec 25 sont 30 %
de demandes en emplois dans les 3 ans au
relais dès lors que tout ce qui touche
le tour de france prend des proportions
la fois affectif passionnel bon donc
c'est quelque chose on est dans la
démesure vers une forme de démesure et
les champions sont des êtres des mesures
la puissance d'exposition du tour de
france va être décuplée par le
déferlement médiatique d'autant que lors
de ses années 80 le paysage audio
duel est bouleversée apparition les
chaînes privées création de canal +
premier contrat d'exclusivité 1982
quatrième victoire pour bernard hinault
mais l'année d'après hinault blessé et
contraint de renoncer
et ils ont une mémoire avec des
béquilles à mon bureau je savais pas
pourquoi il met et me dit voilà je suis
plus chez renault je voudrais recourir
est-ce que vous accepteriez d'un sponsor
rien équipe
j'étais très hésitant bien que passionné
de cyclisme j'avais pas fait de foot
encore à l'époque et ce qui m'a
complètement convaincu c'est jeudi mais
vous êtes blessé
ce que vous allez revenir ml j'ai une
chance sur deux je trouve ça incroyable
d'honnêteté que dire une chance sur deux
mots rédigés 900 / dj aurait sûrement
pas cru et là j'ai dit ce mec vraiment
c'est quelqu'un de formidable joie à
celui qui m'a donné envie de faire du
cyclisme et à messieurs bonsoir jamais
sans doute ces dix dernières années on a
vécu tour de france plus passionnant
plus passionnés puis incertain quant à
la victoire finale
décidément nous vivons le foll course
absolument fantastique déclare jean-paul
entre leurs opinions et bernard hinault
si l'autre est si facile où elle a pas
facile il a l'air facile en tout cas
difficile quand bernard hinault
la résurrection de bernard hinault sous
la houlette de bernard tapie n'aura pas
lieu
en 1984 il est battu par un jeune
champion français laurent fignon qui
remporte avec panache son deuxième tour
de france bernard tapie ne renonce pas
pour gagner le tour de france
il est prêt à y mettre le prix pourquoi
à votre avis l'homme d'affaires français
le plus célèbre bernard tapie
cherche-t-il à engager dans son équipe
cycliste le champion du monde américain
greg lemond l'américain lehman c'est le
futur
à 23 ans vainqueur du tour de l'avenir
82 champion du monde 83 lemon est un bon
investissement même s'il paraît coûteux
9 millions de francs une broutille ont
fait aux bernard tapie - 2 5% du budget
promotionnel de look aux états unis j'ai
surtout amener nouveau salaire parce que
dans le cyclisme
c'était vraiment le sport le plus
exigeant le plus dur est le moins payé
donc tapis il a cette approche
d'entrepreneur il arrive et dit combien
gagne t gala huit mille balles bon moi
je le prends à 15000 et puis voilà ça
s'est passé comme ça les cours ont
regagné le swing les mecs qui étaient
qu'il donnait à fond et une espèce
d'accord entre les différents sponsors
pour pas payer l'équipe dont il crée une
très bonne équipe
et puis il est dans un monde où un monde
paysan au bon sens du terme
ou quelqu'un qui sait mener les hommes a
plus de chances que quelqu'un qui ne
sait pas les modèles détapisser faire ça
et puis en termes de communication
d'entregent de il a donné un grand coup
de pied à faux meyer du cyclisme le fait
que les salaires explose n'est pas lié à
tapis mais lier tout simplement à la
présence des médias
de plus en plus nombreux de la
télévision de la mondialisation de
du tour de france par voie de
conséquence des salaires
des salaires montent donc c'est pas ta
pizza fait monter mais la télévision
1985 pour la première fois une chaîne de
télévision antenne 2 arash l'exclusivité
des images du tour de france c'est le
début de l'explosion du montant des
droits pour la première fois une chaîne
de télévision achète les droits du tour
et c'est sous les équipes d'antenne 2
qui se retrouvent loger avec la
direction du tour ça voulait dire
simplement enfin ça c'était fort de sens
parce que ça voulait dire qu'à partir de
là l'équipe et le parisien sait lire les
deux journaux qui avaient porté
l'organisation du tour
historiquement n'étaient plus les médias
partenaires du tour mais que ce média
partenaire en toute logique parce que
c'est l'évolution de la société et tout
est comme ça le smédias partenaire
devenait antenne 2 avec l'exclusivité
antenne 2 mettant en oeuvre un
dispositif sans précédent sur le tour de
france
bonjour bonsoir nous sommes à plumelec
dans le morbihan pour le premier journal
du tour de plus en plus deux confrères
étrangers venus de colombie
japon et même de nouvelle zélande oui ça
augmente du fait que de plus en plus le
peloton s'internationalise le tour de
france point le plus en plus de
rayonnement à l'extérieur et enfin les
médias étrangers accorde beaucoup de
place à l'événement tour de france c'est
l'explosion médiatique en 1986 800
journalistes accrédités 75 pays reprenne
les images du tour 150 millions de
téléspectateurs à travers le monde
[Musique]
à chacun son tour à chacun son tour
jacques chancel ne pouvait imaginer
meilleur titre pour sa nouvelle émission
à chacun son tour c'est ce que vos
requêtes très bernard tech à bernard
hinault le tour 85
il rentre ainsi dans le gotha des
quintuples vainqueurs à l'égal de
anquetil et merckx à greg lemon le tour
87 et on a accepté l'idée et l'année
dernière greg s'est sacrifié pour
bernard
cette année on a promis à greg qui
serait co leader et qui ferait son tour
pour le gagner et on a comme objectif
que le meilleur gagne
tous les chronos en bataille ici sur la
ligne d'arrivée de l'alpe d'huez
ils font 50 km avant avec l état ne s
est jamais intervient qu à ce moment là
et là il ya une foule considérable
considérable continuons à mam a raconté
après que comme quand il a mis la foule
qui crie hurle est son nom n avais la
chair le boul
alors écoutez moi j'ai pas assez de mots
pour décrire ce que j'ai vécu
aujourd'hui parce que ça c'est
je ne sais pas comment le dire c'est
c'est impossible de transmettre ça pour
moi l'alpe d'huez c'est une journée que
j'ai vécue comme la finale de la coupe
d'europe parce que personne se souvient
mais c'est un festival de l'équipe
incroyable une espèce de rayonnement
chever d'un raid au restaurant
deux visages un peu tendu mais n'a pas
tendu par la douleur tendu par
la poire un oeil neuf ans avant qu'il
termine tholot
tous les deux en se tenant par l'épaule
j'ai pensé tout à l'heure j'ai un moment
si ça va pas se terminer comme ça
[Applaudissements]
on laboure évidemment il ya une mise en
scène parce que c'est à bernard tapie
leurs quatre ans et qui leur a demandé
de passer la ligne la main dans la main
mais là en on peut l'accepter parce que
c'était quand même une belle chose pour
le tour de france mais qu'elle paie
lequel belfond
pourtant qu'un bernard temps pour ça
c'est une énorme connerie je les mulots
beaucoup ça en particulier sur la
présence de look aux états unis car le
taux de notoriété de lemon était zéro en
tout cas bien inférieure à une once i
know était bien plus vendeur aux états
unis que lemon mais bien plus ce qui a
fait dire par un tas de connards en
particulier dans l'équipe que à un
moment j'avais favorisé la victoire de
lemon au détriment dino pour le marché
américain
si bernard hinault gagne ce tour de
france il aura gagné six fois
si greg lemond gagne ce tour de france
on gagne un lien sur votre avenir aux
états unis parlons parlons clairement on
arrive où on n'a pas attendu que greg
beugnot tour de france pour qu'ils
assurent notre avenir aux états unis
n'ont pas ça serait quand même mieux
grâce à greg on a vendu 250 mille paires
de pénal aux états unis il a pas encore
gagné tour de france
[Applaudissements]
c'est servir lemon vous allez me dire
mais bon ça veut dire citron il ya les
corps c'est parce qu'il est président ou
pas giscard a fait son petit tour sur le
tour on ne lui fera pas porter le
chapeau
[Musique]
après le tour 87 verdun tapis quitte le
cyclisme pour le football et l'olympique
de marseille sur quatre participations
son équipe va remporter deux tours de
france félix lévitan quitte la direction
du tour de france cycliste trois lignes
qui met fin à 25 ans de direction du
tour de france pour monsieur félix
lévitan félix lévitan est éjecté de la
direction du tour de france à cause d'un
grave différend sur la gestion des
droits télévisés aux états unis dix ans
après la mort des milliers amaury c'est
une page qui se tourne
une génération qui cède la place jacques
goddet 82 ans prend sa retraite
un an plus tard le fils spirituel de
henri desgrange aura dirigé le tour de
france pendant 40 ans philippe amaury
prend en main les rênes de l'empiré créé
à la libération par son père il nomme le
tennisman jean-pierre courcol à la tête
de son groupe
tous deux ont conscience que la
télévision a définitivement bouleverser
la donne il faut jamais oublier que le
le tour de france au départ n'était pas
une épreuve seuls le tour de france
était inventée par des granges depuis
derrière
menés par par gobeil les lévites ans
comme une opération promotionnelle
chargé d'améliorer les ventes du
quotidien l'équipe et puis ensuite du
quotidien le parisien ce cordon
ombilical entre le tour de france et les
journaux organisateurs philippe amaury
et jean-pierre courcol considère qu'il
est désormais un obstacle à la
prospérité du tour de france la première
action j'ai fait c'est d'essayer de
séparer les gens à l'époque surtout le
tour de france vous avez des panneaux
publicitaires s'étaient 90% le parisien
l'équipe plus quelques sponsors j'ai
séparé tous nous organisations sportives
c'est une chose le quotidien c'en est
une autre
l'aed peut-être aux ventes de l'autre
mais il faut séparer les genres si on
veut faire vraiment de ces épreuves des
épreuves professionnelles et exemplaire
il faut qu'elle soit autonome
complètement et elles gagnent leur vie
ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on a introduit
le marketing dans le tour de france que
ça a changé les choses visuellement et
la télévision arrive en force au même
moment
apportez également beaucoup et ça a été
le départ du redéploiement du tour de
france au plan au plan finances
[Musique]
15 juillet 1988 villard de lans pedro
delgado subi un contrôle antidopage
contrôle positif
les organisateurs et le pouvoir sportif
décide d'attendre le résultat de la
contre expertise pour révéler ce qui
serait un scandale sans précédent dans
l'histoire du tour un maillot jaune
d'opter jacques goddet présent pour la
dernière fois sur le tour de france est
dans la confidence
j'étais là dans cinq ans quand j'ai
appris que que delgado était elle était
et avait été positif et on était à
quatre jour d'arrivée du tour se trouve
savez et je dis bien souvent les types
fois reste du monde avait peur et j'ai
pensé qu'il fallait qu'ils fassent ça se
dénouent ils me disent passe quelque
chose de très grave et je voudrais
puisse régler cette affaire je te le dis
aux points de lorraine il faut pas que
ça s'ébruite
il faut voir de quelle manière nous
pouvons travailler delgado qui était
maillot jaune qui nous arrivons sur
paris delgado a été révélé positif
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce qui peut vous faire
vraiment raté ce maillot je ne plus rien
sauf un incident inattendu
non parce qu'ils avaient peur de quelque
chose à 7 minutes particulière il est
maintenant 18 heures et 150 cas dans
rien bien de tous je crois que demain il
y aura vraiment beaucoup de bruit dans
l'air il se passera énorme et onshore je
ne sais pas je le sens comme ça à demain
et tout à l'heure à 19h30
merci je prends l'antenne après
l'émission de jacques chancel et joue
l'antenne et jeudi voilà selon nos
informations jean paul conditionnelle
parce qu'il faut toujours être prudent
mais je l'avais vérifier jeudi selon nos
informations pedro delgado aurait été
notifiée officiellement d'un contrôle
positif c'est la bombe atomique
bonsoir lorsque nous lancions hier soir
en conclusion du journal du tour ce qui
allait devenir la sphère delgado une
précision de notre seul souci c'était
l'information
quelle reconnaissance du pouvoir acquis
par la télévision que de voir jacques
godet homme de presse écrite vénéré par
ses pairs
réservez ce scoop au journaliste
d'antenne 2 la télévision devient cette
année là plus qu'un simple diffuseurs
détenteurs de droits elle devient l'un
des acteurs majeurs de l'événement
[Applaudissements]
c'est un maillot jaune delgado dopé qui
avait absorbé un produit en plus qui
étaient sur la liste de produits
interdits du comité international
olympique mais qui ne l'était pas encore
à quelques jours près ses analystes ne
lui c'est delgado on reçoit un maillot
jaune pour combien de temps
that is the quest heures ce qui a permis
au président de l'otc y de l'époque qui
était un espagnol entre parenthèses de
nous imposer a pas d'autre mot de garde
et delgado dans le tour et de l'emmener
aux champs-elysées jusqu'aux
champs-elysées avec son maillot jaune
jacques godet a laissé passer et tarbes
cette information m'a donné ma livrer ce
secret parce qu'il voulait sauver le
tour autrement la chose les journalistes
l'ont reçu la chose aurait été
découverte à l'arrivée à paris où il y
avait des milliers des milliers
d'espagnols ou le ministre je ne sais
plus il y avait 2-3 ministre espagnol
qui venait pour saluer delgado sera
était épouvantable il pouvait inquiéter
non seulement le patron du tour de
france mais sur toi grand diplomate
avait tout prévu
il avait dit faisons le spect le
scandale avant pour ensuite nous en
délivrer nord très astucieux
[Applaudissements]
fin 1988 jean pierre qu'on colle nomme
jean marie leblanc la tête du tour de
france où jean marie leblanc le jeune
jean clément des pelotons pour moi ça va
pas mal un jour mieux un jour moi bien
journaliste à la voix du nord puis
responsable de la rubrique cyclisme au
journal l'équipe
il s'impose très vite comme le
successeur naturel de jacques goddet sa
mission concilier l'expansion économique
et médiatique du tour avec la
crédibilité sportive de la compétition
pour ses débuts dans la voiture
directorial jean marie leblanc ne
pouvait rêver tour de france plus
palpitant que le tour 1989
tout au long du duel qui nous intéresse
vraiment elle succède à péter le définit
on s'en va c'est à lemon maintenant de
tenter de réagir lucidité et lehmann qui
s'effondre à son tour attention grand
grand grand moment eu tour la lemond est
en train de s'effondrer
mais c'est laurent fignon qui fait
l'exploit du jour pour l'instant fignon
lancé comme une bombe robert grands
moments du tour de france fignon va
peut-être reprendre le même jour et
c'est maintenant que ça commence le
décompte à cette extraordinaire il a
perdu son maillot tous les chronos
offert de souriau laurent fignon
mais aujourd'hui c'est un nouveau
spectacle qui avait de 12 qui disait
d'ailleurs dans une des premières étapes
que ça servait à rien de faire un film
sur le tour de france parce que chaque
jour il ya un film noir
en vingt secondes il a perdu le tour
laurent fignon s'il n'est pas là
attention il reste maintenant qu dans
quatre secondes il y restera dix
secondes
voilà dix secondes il seconde pour nous
en mettent pas faisait si c'est vraiment
un 4-3-2-1 l'opinion a perdu le tour de
france 80 la pluie secondes laurent
fignon a perdu le tour de france laurent
fignon a perdu le tour de france
dans la dernière étape jalonnée de ma
vie je n'oublie dès ce moment une
véritable folie un suspense jusqu'au
bout y a on sait jamais ce qu'il
arrivait le public et la connaît les
règles et sans conscience que jusqu'au
bout quoi jusqu'à la fin cc c'est
fantastique
il fait alors que leur ennui est allé
pleurer dans son coin
l'euro effondré là bas touchés sur les
champs elysées droite nous avons suivi
le plus grand tour de france tour
voir ce qu'ils viennent se dérouler
l'ars c'est une dramaturgie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai vu comme vous l'a dit sol la
ferveur la ferveur populaire du tour de
france c'est quand même quelque chose
non je la connais quand j'avais 13 14
ans j'allais assister aux arrivées
d'étapes dans le nord de la france dans
les flandres où je passais sur mes
vacances j'ai vu gagner je sais pas moi
les policiers leduc
ou alors c'est ça le remet antoyé 1 loin
derrière nous mais la grande nouvelle
c'est la reconduction du contrat liant
le service public au tour de france il
faut dire clairement
tf1 a mis beaucoup d'argent sur la table
voulait avoir le tour de france quels
ont été les arguments qui ont fait que
finalement c'est antenne 2 fr3 que le
tour de france vaut cher ivo de plus en
plus cher parce que c'est une
compétition internationale
extraordinaire
il fallait pouvoir payer le tour de
france le juge de prix mais pas à
n'importe quel prix
au moment de la négociation comme
toujours dans ces cas là tout le monde
veut gagner il y en est quelquefois
limites sur la manière dont on s'y prend
pour essayer de remporter deux manceaux
et je me souviens très bien que des fins
bois à l'époque j'ai en face de moi
jean-pierre courcol et genre en un dans
un premier temps puis jean claude killy
qui va arriver sur les entrefaites après
avoir bouclé les jeux d'albertville à
dire que s'établit entre nous une belle
relation et je vais pouvoir jouer
beaucoup de la complémentarité des deux
chaînes qui est en train de s'inscrire
et qui démontre aux uns et aux autres
effectivement que la force du service
public jouant sur les deux l'aide des
deux tableaux à la fois prêtre
formidable et moi j'ajoute à cela un
autre argument c'est que le tour de
france est une société est une affaire
privée mais là quand même
c'est presque un service public il fait
partie du patrimoine national je sentais
bien dans les troupes que que que tous
les dirigeants avait envie de rester sur
le service public
s'il y avait une réelle différence
financière à prestation égale je précise
sera le sauteur fin je me souviens
toujours d'ailleurs de patrick le lay
furieux qui me dit bon bah on a perdu la
négociation mais je je veux voir pour
cole et kylie demain dans mon bureau
dans un premier temps j'ai refusé
d'aller à la réunion à tf1 parce que
j'ai estimé que c'était fini dont ils
essaient de dire à courre poehl qu'il
peut encore augmenter les droits que de
toute façon c'est malhonnête free a pas
eu d'appel d'offres vraiment enfin ils
essaient de porter ça maintenant faire
un contentieux sur le plan juridique il
ya une batterie d'avocats dans la salle
et trouvant ses vecteurs et claude n'a
pas apprécié à l'époque
enfin ce genre de combat on le gagne ou
on perd en l'occurrence et elle
s'annonce public il avait gagné et vous
avez le football et dans lequel vous
êtes le parc ne voulais pas tout avoir
quand même pas du tout d'ailleurs fait
par exemple s'ils feront le tour de
france je trouve que c'est
remarquablement fait par la deux et vous
vouliez aussi le tout allait bien mais
votre enfant tout une grande épreuve
mais trop d'arguments réellement
technique pour dire qu'on fera mieux
mais vont regretter de ne pas l'avoir
ah oui oui en date et beaucoup pensaient
que jamais il annonce en anglais comme
ça je pense à la une en détail mais
c'est un très beau spectacle
les civils sont bien sûrs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le spectacle du tour de france va être
révolutionné par cette caméra installée
sur hélicoptère la fameuse west gamme
doté d'une stabilité étonnante et d'un
téléobjectif très puissant cette caméra
va donner toute sa mesure dans les
années 90 sous l'égide du réalisateur
régis forissier la magie de cette caméra
le tour de france devient le spectacle
de la france fut lucienne paysager
vieille cité rivières les châteaux et
par là même l'audience du tour augmente
bien au delà des seuls aficionados du
sport cycliste
après la géographie c'est à la météo que
vont s'attaquer les techniciens de la
sfp alors qu'aujourd'hui nous avons un
temps exécrable sur la ville d'arrivée
de la bourboule que c'est difficile
d'acheminer l'image jusque là et là on
va retrouver la beauté grâce à une
manipulation qui m'échappe complètement
est en train de faire des miracles c'est
étonnant d'arriver à voir des images
dans ces conditions les éléments
déchaînés empêche les hélicoptères de
décoller la retransmission des images
est alors impossible jusqu'à cette
fameuse étape de 1992
c'est une première mondiale les images
des caméras motos sont retransmises en
direct grâce à un avion relais volant au
dessus de la couche nuageuse
[Applaudissements]
de france dans le brouillard je me
répète la vidéo près des murs et on ne
voit rien
c'est incroyable on ne sait plus
est ce que le fait de tout montrer ne va
pas démythifier le spectacle ça c'était
vraiment une question importante que mes
prédécesseurs s'étaient posées aussi et
qu'on se pose encore aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs dans d'autres sports qui ne
sont pas encore couverts techniquement
parfaitement comme la voile par exemple
mais pas encore sur les mers avec les
concurrents et on dit le rêve la légende
etc jouent un rôle dans la réussite de
ces sports donc c'était un vrai choix
on a fait le choix d'aller plus loin de
tout montrer tout montrer en direct la
course son public son décor quelle que
soit la météo sur des milliers de
kilomètres
on vise formidablement bien cette course
je rappelle grâce à l'avion voilà merci
pour ce spectacle la torture est il allé
le chercher sur des patients du coup du
complot partout extraordinaire
aujourd'hui quand cette étape douleurs
de dos car je la tête revers nous
n'avons pas vécu le tour de france
spectacle furtif par essence devient à
la télévision entièrement visible
la presse écrite est définitivement
dépossédé du récit de la course
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mille deux cents journalistes 360
journaux ou agences de presse au moins
150 pays diffuseurs des images du tour
la télévision n'a pas tué la légende du
tour de france elle la transfigurer la
légende est devenue mondiale et c est qu
télévisée résonne désormais sur les cinq
continents
[Applaudissements]
année après année l'audimat du tour bat
des records jusqu'à des sommets
inimaginables pour une épreuve cycliste
parfois 70 % de parts de marché dans le
dernier quart d'heure de certaines
étapes de montagne par voie de
conséquence des sponsors affluent les
droits télévisés augmente même si
l'explosion des droits télé du tour est
loin très loin d'atteindre les sommes
vertigineuses payés par les télévisions
pour les jeux olympiques où le football
on a vraiment gagné en professionnalisme
certains disent aussi en gigantisme donc
à partir de là des marques comme les
notes doivent ensuite pouvoir justifier
d'un retour sur investissement
et ça ça passe par une déclinaison de
toutes les variables du mix marketing
avec un véritable objectif
d'augmentation des ventes du produit
lors des années 90 celle de la saga
indurain la télévision a permis au tour
de france d'accéder à une prospérité
sans précédent dans son histoire
prospérité sportive prospérité
commercial
c'est évident que c'est énorme entre la
presse écrite puisque il ya des
retombées ya des images et nous on est
notamment sur la ligne d'arrivée donc
tous les jours des images humiliantes
kate apparaît c'était non mais si on y
est c'est qu'on ne trouve un intérêt
je ne donnerai pas de chiffres irex
équivaut anglo à deux campagnes de
d'affichage nationale à peu près c'est à
peu près 1,5
moi je dis qu'il faut toujours prendre
le problème dans le sens de 1 les
nécessités sportive de les nécessités
économiques
car si on pense prioritairement à faire
de l'argent on va en faire un an deux
ans trois ans mais fatalement ce sera au
détriment de du bon déroulement de la
compétition qui sera d'une manière ou
d'une autre
noyer étouffé par trop de pub par trop
de contraintes et donc la qualité du
sport s'en ressentent s'en ressentira et
on entrera a invariablement dans une
spirale du recul 1998 année noire dans
la légende du tour de france la veille
du prologue à dublin en irlande où il
goûte le soigneur de l'équipe festina
dirigé par bruno roussel est arrêté en
possession de 400 fioles de p o et de
produits dopants d'emblée la suspicion
s'abat sur toute la caravane
certains laissent même supposer
l'existence d'une sorte d'omerta allant
des laboratoires pharmaceutiques aux
coureurs en passant par les journalistes
spécialisés les organisateurs et la
télévision le dopage existait bien sûr
personne n'ignorait que dopage existait
mais je pense que la presse a été dans
son nom dans son ensemble absolument
coach et moi j'assume aujourd'hui
d'avoir pu dire en 97
le dopage existe sûrement encore mais au
moins avec des éducateurs des gens va en
plus puis solid steel bruno roussel on
est à l'abri d'excès le sourire figé
bruno roussel part pour la prison
d'arras où il passera la nuit
à ce moment là bien peu savent quel coup
de théâtre vient de se jouer
monsieur bruno roussel a expliqué aux
enquêteurs
lesquels avaient les éléments les
conditions dans lesquelles une gestion
concertée de l'approvisionnement des
coureurs en produits dopants était
organisée entre la direction les
médecins
le soigneur et les coureurs c'est à une
organisation qui rassemble les
organisations un peu mafieuse que leur
fondé sur le secret moi j'aurai toujours
un doute sur le fait que tout cela et
puis rester comme ça inconnu ça me
paraît difficile qui devrait parler
parler entre eux il fait savoir
je pense pas qu'il y avait dans la
caravane sur les mille journalistes
un journaliste qui savait que bruno
roussel et les autres on organisait le
dopage de cette manière là mais ne fait
pas un feuilleton policier quand vous
êtes en train de faire pour détruire une
image une image de l entourage cycliste
qu'il ya qui touche beaucoup de monde et
ça en ce moment cette politique vous
êtes enfant d'assassiner le vélo voilà
merci à vous
la télé est complice du dopage parce que
si des coureurs ont roulé à 39 km heure
ça irait pas pour la télé c'est la plus
grande stupidité que jamais entendu un
tour humain un tour avec des
défaillances et un tour à 38 km heure
c'est le meilleur scénario pour la télé
donc faut pas dire n'importe quoi
l'athénée que les gars soient chargées
monte l'école assis sur la selle la
vouge fermer saturn spectacle le pays
représente une rupture dans l'histoire
du dopage
cette molécule remet en cause comme
jamais auparavant la crédibilité du
spectacle sportif l'égalité des chances
or en 1998
le pays n'est toujours pas détectable
alors que la rumeur de sa généralisation
dans le monde sportif va croissant
inquiète les dirigeants du cyclisme
français du tour de france font parvenir
au président de l'uss et y ait au
ministre des sports un courrier
prémonitoire et alarmistes daté du mois
d'octobre 1996 soit 19 mois avant
l'affairé festina les techniques de
dopage utilisés sont très sophistiqués
sur le plan scientifique et nous
craignons que ce soit une véritable
tentation professionnels la france peut
apporter une contribution essentielle à
la recherche scientifique
cela doit être une priorité car il
s'agit d'un véritable problème de santé
publique
nous étions tous dans la tente de la
détection de l'epo et notre lettre
voulait dire dépêchez vous monsieur le
ministre
dépêchez vous monsieur le président il
commence à y avoir urgence voilà alors
qu'on ne dise après coup que nous nous
soyons nous ayons été complice me fait
sourire il faut bien comprendre que le
dopage est un vrai problème pour le même
pour le spectacle sportif
à terme le dopage cura spectacle sportif
est si vrai qu'on peut aller au bout de
l'horreur la génétique se met également
étudié ce qui comment on peut rendre un
un sportif plus performants s'approche
petit à petit de l'homme bionique on
peut modifier l'être humain en faire une
sorte de robocop capable de tout il ya
de moins en moins d' aventure humaine
est de plus en plus d'organisations
économiques et techniques et mettez donc
médicales et scientifiques et on se
demande où l'argent peut mener le sport
parce que c'est quand même ça qui est à
l'origine
l'un dans l'autre tout l'époque est un
peu comme ça c'est un peu schématique de
dire ça mais toute l'époque est un peu
comme ça pourquoi le cyclisme y
échapperaient malheureusement pourquoi
il s'est liquéfié chapais pilule pour
maigrir pilules pour dormir pilule pour
jouir pilule pour rajeunir tricher avec
son corps triche avec son âge tricher
avec la pilule du bonheur
tel est souvent la voie de la réussite
dans une société qu'ils portent au
pinacle la compétition décor et le règne
du paraître
il faut essayer que le cyclisme est le
sport en général échappe à saké au moins
un univers qui échappent à cette à cette
forme d'évolution de la société du tour
de france 98 et je remercie le public
qui a été très très qui nous a
énormément soutenu et qui vont qui va
encore nous soutenir
je donne rendez-vous et mai prochains
aucun sportif professionnel il va
rentabiliser sa carrière il a deux ans
trois ans quatre ans cinq ans pour le
faire donc il faut que je prenne le plus
d'argent possible le plus de victoires
le plus de tout tout de suite donc la
tentation du dopage l'enfant est
extraordinairement fort au même moment à
l'autre bout de la ville une
perquisition se déroule à l'hôtel où
loge l'équipe cycliste ça suffit on
reste calme
laissez nous faire notre travail
tranquillement vraiment aucune raison de
s'énerver
les journalistes sportifs de vienne où
sont presque contraint de devenir des
journalistes d'investigation des
affaires de la rubrique presque info
géné comme on dit dans le jargon avec
des chroniques policière des descentes
de police sur l'auto stop on découvre le
visage de jan ullrich marqué comme ça
par la douleur lui qui cachait cycle
injuste est mato tout ce qu'il
ressentait tout ce que son corps disait
eh bien cette fois ci le visage peu
nombreux de chasse on joue donc
évidemment l'événement change de nature
il change de visage et changent de
nature c'est comme jekyll et hyde et
tout d'un coup les gens qui étaient
venus voir
jekyll il tombe sur hyde avec ses
villages monstrueux dont certains ne
veulent pas le voir d'autres le regarde
en face et même le provoque en dix ans
mais il est temps de nettoyer tout ça a
une image incroyable avec le peloton
arrêter les puristes toute la caravane
des voitures c'est absolument insensé
écoutez dès que vous pouvez peut-être
absolument gérard nord on a tous et
c'est une image
évidemment complètement inédite sur le
tour de france à la gamme permet bel
agrément général à moto de type hercule
lyon n'est pas produire un moment de
partage autour de moi en tant
qu'observateur et en tant que média qui
retransmettait ce tour
ça m'aurait pas choqué qu'il s'arrête ça
m'aurait pas choqué parce que le 8 ca
serait rentré dans la légende du tour ou
si c'est un geste important tannique et
un mental health endosse à ce jour là
pour la première fois de son histoire le
tour de france va si les coureurs
excédés par la multiplication des
perquisitions policières exigent des
garanties les organisateurs pour
continuer la compétition
jean marie leblanc fait face il
souffrait énormément de ces espaces est
un amoureux du cyclisme un ancien coron
ancien journaliste et il avait un
objectif qui était de mener le tour à
paris et c'est sympa toujours été gagné
à un moment où c'était limite limite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
81 18 janvier où l'enjeu c'est
formidable ça ressemble à ça ressemble à
un film
vous savez je connais rien en grade de
l'armée mais le général qui vont
lieutenant-colonel étudie maintenant
votre boulot c'est d'emmener mes hommes
de l'autre côté de la rivière
et puis pendant une heure et demie se
fasse mine troicki et puis le gard dans
le casque il est humain on voit qu'il
est qu'il aime ses hommes et oui ils les
emmènent le cristal bien relancer ça
mission accomplie jean marie leblanc son
amour des coureurs le respect qu'il leur
inspire ont fini par convaincre la
majorité du peloton de rejoindre paris
pour les organisateurs l'avenir du tour
de france et tout ce qu'il représente
comme enjeu sportif et économique était
préservé le dopage n'en était pas venu à
bout en revanche la réaction du public
m'a profondément troublé le même public
qui pendant dix ans vous avez dit super
pour les images
si vous me lisez la presse vous dites il
va nous dire ah ben dis donc nous avait
bien eu en fait c'était beau de père et
vous avez 12 avec 99% des gens qui
lisent arrêté salle où la télé arrêter
de parler de dopage laissez les vivre
alors ce qui nous a tout de suite frappé
dans les études selon le feu c'est que
la véritable décalage entre la
perception du public
le plat perception que le public avait
de nouvelles de tours et la perception
qu'en ont reflété certains médias arabes
ou dit attends je comprends pas et puis
après vous lisez le courrier et vous
vous avez reçue avec les gens ils
veulent qu'une chose c'est qu'on les
laisse rêver mais j'avoue ça sans
trouble un petit peu quand même
ça me troue le même beaucoup le tour de
france fait partie aujourd'hui du
patrimoine culturel français
il dépasse même le cadre du simple
événement sportif donc à partir de là
nous tous deux se retrouvent dans cet
événement c'est le seul événement
populaire gratuit auquel ils couvrent
accès en famille
sur les routes à côté de son poing à
côté de son absence au lieu de vacances
donc pour ces raisons là il a envie que
ça continue à exister donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui nous a très intéressé
[Musique]
le tour de france armstrong
l' affaire festina aura provoqué un
électrochoc salutaire
même si à l'évidence la lutte contre le
dopage est un combat sans fin
inévitablement de nouvelles molécules
sortiront des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques ce combat contre le
dopage relève autant d'un devoir éthique
que d'un impératif économique pour la
survie du sport spectacle
[Applaudissements]
l'attak tom strong qui va revenir comme
une fusée sur marco pantani marco
pantani aura-t-il la force de
s'accrocher
quel bon duel en tout cas si marco
pantani peut s'accrocher en trombe
datékro charline en bons atouts
le tour armstrong l'étape du ventoux
pour condamner dès 1999
le tour a renoué avec les ingrédients
qui ont fondé sa légende 15 millions
personnes au bord des routes pour
applaudir un champion d'exception
vainqueur du cancer la poursuite du
corps de la honte c'est son dauphin au
classement général il est revenu très
facilement lance armstrong
il reste beaucoup d'aisance mais ils
sont su comme contre lens affronte sur
la droite dont la rente une parcelle
bello qui essaye de le dire il se remet
sur sept est admissible soit aussitôt à
fond parce la poursuite de bérat
l'extraterrestre de tour de france tente
de reprendre mais charriant et servian
tu es là
les écarts il ce pas du plus qu'il peut
il va aller la chercher sa victoire
d'étape dans le tour de france l'audimat
du tour de france a retrouvé les niveaux
records de 1997
la durée de la retransmission s'est
encore allongée la présence des médias
étrangers toujours aussi massive en 2002
le tour de france a même été retransmis
pour la première fois en direct en chine
populaire
accélération
lance amstrong yanagi siens quand je
dépends
et c'est une se mettre dans la roue du
champion américain ham cette finale
sous le soleil
la station pyrénéenne il a gagné 7 et r
cette année le tour va fêter son
centenaire
sentant d'une légende écrite par la
presse puis racontée par la radio enfin
rendue visible et magnifié par la
télévision
tant que ces millions de personnes se
presseront chaque été en famille sur les
routes du tour de france
cette légende qui a prospéré lors du 20e
siècle traversera les prochaines
décennies
toujours en direct à la télévision et
demain qui sait sur les écrans des
téléphones portables
[Applaudissements]
voici le premier tour de france terminé
tous mes collaborateurs sont fourbus je
suis ravi et j'aurais voulu que les
heures de travail et d'immenses
satisfactions que la course nous a
données puissent se prolonger
indéfiniment td10 yeux un pareil travail
tant sont douces de semblable
satisfaction j'ai fait bien des rêves
sportifs dans ma vie je n'en avais
jamais connu qui vaille cette réalité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
kelly
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]